hyenas and this is actually I'm going to
tell you a little bit about this big
project that's going on with all of
these people
um and this is actually Franz Jensen
that you saw talk about dolphin
signature whistles yesterday so he's
involved also but um
uh this is actually a project to
understand how uh Collective action is
mediated by Communication in animal
societies and most of the work as you
probably know that's been done on
Collective action has been done on
animals like these birds and flocks or
fish in schools where there are no
differentiated relationships within the
group so we actually
um thought that it would be interesting
to look at some
um communication as it's mediating
Collective action in animals that do
have differentiated relationships not
nearly as many as the types of that
Mickey was just telling you about in
elephants but these animals do have a
lot of different kinds of relationships
this is all project run by Ariana
stranberg peskin who's the pi on this
and what we're doing is actually right
David had sent me an email inviting me
to this uh conference and I said oh wow
I just got back from this other meeting
in Germany uh which we call them the
communication and coordination across
scales we call it Kick-Ass because it's
a kick-ass project but we've got these
three different species so we've got
um spotted hyenas and meerkats and
kawadis and these are all animal they're
all mammalian carnivores they all live
in societies where there are
differentiated relationships but they
have different degrees of spatial
cohesiveness so as if you've anybody
seen near cat Manor you know that
meerkats are always with inside of one
another they move across this plane like
a big amoeba they're really cohesive
kawadis are intermediate and hyenas are
wildly infusion as I'll show you so they
spend a lot of their time actually even
though they belong to these big social
groups they spend a lot of their time
alone
so here are the three species we've
actually now collared entire groups of
all of these and we're just starting to
mess with the analysis of the data the
meerkats are incredibly cool because you
don't even need to anesthetize them you
can come up to them and they will just
put their neck up like this and then you
can put a magnetic collar on and they
it's amazing hyenas are much bigger
production as you can imagine
um but what
what I thought I would do is tell you a
little bit about the study system that
we work in a little bit about the basic
biology of the hyenas then I'll tell you
a little bit about how the Kick-Ass
project is sort of unfolding here and
show you where we are at the moment
so these are animals that occur all over
sub-Saharan Africa literally
um pretty much everywhere south of the
Sahara except in the wettest parts of
the continent and the rainforest but
they live in okavango Delta they live in
the deserts of southern Africa they live
in montane forest and where I studied
them is here in the open grasslands in
Eastern Africa and there have been
long-term studies done on them both in
southern Africa and uh in our work in
Kenya and there's another group that
actually works on hyenas in Tanzania but
I've been working for many years in the
Maasai Mara National Reserve which is
this beautiful open grassland area that
is two degrees south of the Equator and
it's
um gets year-round Sunshine as you can
see and that supports a lot of grass
which supports loads of herbivores which
in turn support High densities of of
carnivores so we have been I went out
there in May of 1988 thinking I would do
a dissertation length project and move
on and I'm still there because these
these animals are so weird and
interesting and we have worked with a
number of different social groups within
the mara this is about the mara is about
1500 square kilometers uh it's bounded
on the south by the Serengeti National
Park in Tanzania and there are a whole
bunch of private conservancies
surrounding the outside but we did a
pilot study here in 2016 and 2017 in
this group and then
um colored an entire clan in between
October and December of 2022.
so this is an area of um really
remarkable biodiversity and high
densities of wildlife as I said we're
two degrees south of the Equator so the
temperature regime remains pretty
similar year round but we get two bouts
of rainfall because uh we're so close to
the intertropica to the equator that the
inner tropical Convergence Zone passes
over us twice here and only once down
here so these guys have one long rainy
season we have two shorter ones and that
drives this thing called The Great
Migration which is where roughly a
million wildebeest in several thousand
zebra go from the southern part of the
Serengeti to uh up to our park in Kenya
and so that means you can look at
sometimes I hardly see any herbivores
and other times you look out in the
whole place has just packed with them so
we have been working with all these
different animals since um 1988 and we
know every individual by its pattern of
unique spots and ear damage and so forth
uh we spent several hours every day
mainly around Dawn and dusk sitting in
cars like that one and the hyenas are
they've all grown up with this car in
their environment so they're very well
habituated to it and most of what we do
is observe them and one of the things
that we have recorded very religiously
since the study began is every single
occurrence in our presence of any
interaction that looked vaguely like
this this is a very low level fight
between Cochise over here and Oliver
Twist Cochise has just brought her
little black Cubs to the communal Dan
Oliver Twist who wants to meet them and
Cochise is lunging up out of this hole
too make her stay away from the Cub so
coaches got her eyes wide open ears
caught forward so she's lunging up out
of its hold for 10 for what was out of
the hole you sure you could see her tail
ends up and bristled as well I mean when
I look at Oliver twists she's doing
exactly the opposite her ears are
plastered back Tails down between her
legs and she is exhibiting all the
classic signs of hyena appeasement
Behavior or submission
and because we've recorded every single
one of these uh types of interactions
we've got a database that now has many
tens of thousands of these interactions
in there and what that means is that we
can actually generate a very clear
picture of the structure of the society
throughout any given time period within
our larger study and so what I've done
here is to take out about 50 hyenas
between Bailey and [__] just so you
can see better what's going on but then
we've ranked these individuals as
animals who win in fights from Murphy
who wins against everybody else in the
society down to Boston who can't meet
anyone else and the same individuals are
listed as as losers across the top so
the numbers in the Matrix just represent
the number of fights that we've seen
where there was a clear winner and a
clear loser and as you can see there are
very few fight outcomes that are
inconsistent with the rank orderings
that we've identified here and this is
very much like what you'd find in a
macaque Society or baboon Society with
one interesting twist which is that all
the breeding males are here and all the
reading females are up there ahead of
all the males and when we first went out
there in the 80s our goal was to
understand Social Development and
understand how females come to dominate
males in this weird society and how
animals know where they're supposed to
slide in Well turns out their mother's
intervene on their behalf so that Navajo
here interviewing on behalf of her kids
and so they could dominate Bailey and
everybody below Bailey
but
um they keep those ranks pretty much as
long as they live in the clan where they
were born so you've got all sorts of
stuff going on there
okay so we have in addition to
individuals having ranks uh all the
members of a particular natural line in
this present in the clan at once
um uh occupy adjacent rank positions in
the hierarchy so here's the member of
the alpha metro line which tends to be
the largest just because they have the
highest priority of access to food and
so forth and so as in oh sorry yeah
no
um no sometimes they can hurt each other
very badly but no I've never seen
anybody fight to the death well I've
seen an adult kill a cub but that's you
know you wouldn't call that fair Flight
By Any stretch the imagination
but most of the males who are doing all
the breeding are coming in from
somewhere else they all lead voluntarily
nobody chases them out but they all
change groups and they can go from
bracket shoulder up there has a son he's
been built from being ranked two or
three in the whole clan down to 70th
because he slots in at the very bottom
of the hierarchy in the new clan that he
joins yeah
but by their unique spots so they're
black when they're born but as soon as
they won't they have spots that they
keep the the same pattern for their
whole life it's like
yeah that's right so our main research
tools are binoculars on the photo album
for each plan
but um so as in elephant societies we
can see that there's all these different
ways in which hunting and social
relationships vary both with kinship and
social rank also sex and age
so um as it turns out uh resource
competition uh outcomes of it uh are
strongly dependent on an individual's
rank you can see that on this kill some
hyenas are up there eating and they're
other ones who are just hanging around
in the periphery those are the lower
ranking ones and they get a much lower
priority of access to food so they get
to eat a lot less
then they're higher ranking counterparts
and that has enormous
um repercussions in virtually every
aspect of the animal's biology here I'm
introducing you to Barbara and Batman
these are two
um six-month-old hyenas who were born
five days apart and this is what they
looked like when they were six months
old Barbara's the daughter of our alpha
female the highest ranking one Batman's
the daughter of our lowest ranking
female and
um
she's growing way way way more slowly
because Barbara's mother can go have her
feel of whatever food she wants she can
use certain food from anybody else in
the society translate it into milk if
effectively has access to ad-lib food
but that affects when breeding starts so
here I'm showing you the age when
females first give birth this is the
cohort where Barbara and Batman were is
Barbara so she starts before she's even
two and a half she's already produced
her first litter here this is Batman so
she was 72 months old when she had her
first litter this one was two and a half
and so uh you can see that the length of
the reproductive lifespan is longer not
only do they breed for longer periods
but the high-ranking females also
produce more offspring per year and they
keep their cubs alive more successfully
and so
um there are just enormous Fitness
consequences too
uh an animal social Rank and here I'm
showing you what happens over 40 years
where a guy who worked with the same
population of hyenas as we did for his
PhD here at Cal Lawrence Frank went out
there in 1979 and he found 19 adult
females president McLean and here we're
looking at the adult females present in
the clan at decade-long intervals after
that and what you can see is whereas K
by up there was only one of 19 females
in 1979 now her descendants occupy G
what's that 60 on the clan and there are
only descendants of four of those
original females left because these
great triangles represent the extinction
of entire natural lands so it's really
um pretty dramatic what the fitness
consequences are of
social rank
oh sorry yes
so you've mentioned terrible negative
Fitness consequences of social rank
you mentioned that when a male leaves
and joins another clan they drop to the
bottom of the social ring so I guess my
two questions are white females never
leave and why do males at the top Everly
right I think the males leave because
the female emails won't make with them
and then they don't plan I think there's
some sort of kibbutz effect or something
that's taking place there but it looks
like turns out the sons of high-ranking
females do much better when they move to
a different Clan than the sons of
low-ranking female so something's
happening during our early development
that shapes their whole reproductive
Futures and you know we actually had
radio colors on a lot of these guys
doing a study of dispersal
um between 19
3 and 96 and
um we had 12 high-ranking sons and 12
low ranking sons in a year after they
all dispersed both 12 of the hierarchy
and son for doing just fine in their new
groups all 12 of the low ranking Sons
were dead so you know it really puts
them on a very challenging course I
asked can I ask one too because that you
skipped over 40 years of data which was
unbelievable can we go back to that
descending Cascade plot of amazingness
yeah sure
yes
this is amazing but can we can we
extrapolate forward another three
decades well yeah but you know I just
wonder
at what point does it is the fitness of
the clan become a problem because
everyone's a descendant of
not correctly because all the males are
changing groups and so there's a huge
amount of gene flow that's that's moving
around you know the genes are moving
around the males so even though this
this you know how her her descendants
occupied all of this these right
positions in the female hierarchy but um
the genetic diversity is enough because
it's male it's really quite High yeah
but none of the females ever start a new
group like if they're BS here at the
bottom yeah
um
yeah we've had a couple of incidents
where the local Masai will for example
poison
um some hyenas go after their livestock
to retaliate they put poison in a
carcass and then all these individuals
get priority of access to it so they die
and then
um you know you definitely see um some
shifting around when that there's a
catastrophe in the high-ranking uh
lineages but um you know I I would have
expected the Payless descendants to buy
all of this by now but somehow is this
you know what does that mean here was
this good luck the good weather what you
know what did you do right that she
she's the only one of these low rate
females who has any descendants present
in the clan anyway I just think that's a
trip and uh yeah
love that figure
um okay and then the last thing I just
need to tell you a little bit about
their life history so female hyenas um
they all breed uh and so they breed year
round and um they keep their cubs at a
communal Den uh where all the animals
who have Cubs in in the sort of one to
twelve month age range will bring them
here they give birth in an isolated
natal den and keep their cubs there for
just a few weeks they then move them to
communal Den where they stay until
they're hmm 11 or 12 months typically
then they start traveling around the
home range originally with their moms
and later on on their own when they're
24 months most Sexes go through puberty
and then females are Philip Patrick they
spend their whole lives in the NATO Clan
where they were born but by contrast
almost 100 of surviving males at some
point after puberty will leave and go to
a neighboring Clan and if they're lucky
they actually make get
um you know incorporated into the clan
and actually get to sire some Cubs there
um so this is the family hyena day this
is all that's left of it it was once a
very big family
um but it's these aren't dogs they're
not cats they're most closely related to
mongooses
um but there's four hyena species the
art wolf which is a little 12 kilo
diminutive hyena that has lost all its
teeth basically and it just eats
termites then we have striped and brown
hyenas here which as the artist is
showing you rely mainly on carrion for
their survival they will make
opportunistic grabs at prey uh as the
artist is showing you here but the only
one of these hyenas probably in the
history of hyenas to ever go after
um you know live prey like this and
still have this big heavy bone cracking
morphology or spotted hyenas which
um live in these big groups and
uh so there's these four unique aspects
of them they're unique with respect to
all carnivores but they're even unique
spot Italians are unique with respect to
none of the other hyenas having these
these traits either so they're very good
Hunters this is the typical menu of
things available to our hyenas in the
mara
and um they are very good uh see this
like the 60 kilo hyena is bringing down
a prey animal that weighs three times
its body mass all by itself uh they're
really great hunters they can run you
know we've driven along behind them at
55 kilometers an hour so they can keep
up a pace like that for a long time and
in southern Africa they even go after
really dangerous creatures like court
but but the fact is that Cooperative
hunting is one of the types of
collective action that we want to look
at in the CCIS project because it's
quite clear from some work we did back
in the 90s that if you add a single this
guy can bring down wildebeest but the
probability of actually catching one
goes up almost 20 percent if somebody
else is helping that one
so very good Hunters these animals also
as you probably are aware these are
female spotted hyenas this is the
clitoris it's enormously elongate
elongated to form this fully erectile
pseudo penis kind of structure and here
the vaginal labia that are folded over
and filled with connective tissue there
to form the structure that really
remarkably looks like a scrotal Sac
nobody understands why they have these
traits but the fact is that coercive sex
doesn't happen in Spanish
so these animals live in great big
social groups called plans the first guy
to go out and study them systematically
had come from Scotland so he got to call
them plans anyway they can range in size
from anywhere about 10 or 11 hyenas to
over over 125 of them and all the
members of a clan know each other
individually and they know each other by
sight by smell by sound um we've done
loads of relevant experiments to say
that they all rear their cubs together
in a communal den and they all defend
the common territory a piece of real
estate over which their mobile prey move
but interesting to me is that the
spotted hyena societies don't look
anything like the societies of any other
mammalian carnivore you can think of so
um here are meerkats again in kiladis
then there's candid groups and lion
Prides but
um these are all relatively small groups
comprised of uh composed of members of
of the same sex that are closely related
to one another so they're small groups
and they have loads of kin and typically
you're only interacting with Ken in
those groups but what we have in
fighting is something that sort of
remarkably convergent with the societies
of baboons and macaques which is to say
that that overall relatedness within
groups is very low we have multiple
overlapping Generations present at any
given time multiple Delta both sections
male dispersal and female filipatory
matrilineal kids subgroups form and the
hierarchical ranked relationships are
just uh just like what you find over
over here and it's all evolved
convergently
and we've been actually studying their
sounds for quite a while and until
recently this was how we
um collected them just sitting out there
with shotgun microphones
again that's again a
play you a few of these of these
vocalizations
um if I can make this work I'll see if
it'll work
[Music]
yeah okay so here's a whoop this is a
bout of whoops there's
another one this is a slow group so this
is their long distance vocalization that
they use to do all of these functions
um
you know this is a male slow whooping
because he think males need to do this
just ties their presence to the members
of a social group but
um they actually every individual's
whoop is unique and
um they know each other by by their
whoops and they can tell who who's
talking
[Music]
um
okay and so we know we know that they
can actually increase the urgency with
which other hyenas are called by
shrinking it
and it just comes really fast when
they're very excited or scared about
something
but so here are all these are all the
measurements that we can take of a
particular whoop bout here and they
don't house the moon like wolves do they
instead they put their
uh places down against the substrate and
seem to use that as a sounding border
so these are groans so this is another
this is like a come hither vocalization
at least that's how I think of it um
[Music]
very deep voice
I'm trying to move on okay and here
these are called laughing hyenas and
here's the reason
most
that's the giggle so anyway um there's
loads of other ones and I'm just showing
you some
um spectrograms of some of these other
vocalizations and uh we had originally
um thought that these were discrete
signals but in fact they really grade
into one another and
um you can actually see that they're
forming grown whoops or grown Grunts and
these um in these funny kind of hybrid
calls
so um what I want to focus on in this
telling you a little bit about the CCIS
project is these um three kinds of
collaborative actions or Collective
actions which are hunting behavior that
we just talked about um Clan Wars which
is where two teams of hyenas in
neighboring Clans come and fight usually
over a carcass and then interactions
with lions and
um
uh let me lions are very dangerous to
hyenas they kill a lot of hyenas
um but so one of the questions we're
asking about
um Hyena's coordinating group hunts is
whether they're even communicating at
all with one another or it seems to me
watching them hunt that they could
easily be using stigmergic organization
of the hunt where they're just following
simple rules of thumb like keep the prey
animal between you and another hyena or
some simple things like that
um but but there are certain other types
of interactions like clan wars and
interactions with lions where they
clearly are
um very heavily communication based and
um so we're we want to understand how
Groupons are initiated and they're often
initiated at scenes like this is It's a
communal Den in the evening where when
females bringing home a big chunk of
giraffe that she's stumbled upon but so
one of the questions we want to know is
okay are hyenas like Lassie most of you
um are too young for this but if you
grew up watching Lassie on TV you know
know that when her little boy Timmy
falls down the well she will go back and
get to his parents and very patiently to
start towards the door and if they don't
come it's just like what Mickey and Josh
were describing with the elephants
she'll just turn around and wait yeah
no
no and um it seems like it would be
maladaptive because everybody could say
oh the onions are hunting over here
we're gonna go someplace else that's
what I thought they're not coordinating
Myself by communicating well they might
be coordinating by communicating but not
vocally so
um they do and so so do a lot of
carnivores they do these um what we call
them greeting ceremonies to get all
excited I think get everybody on the
same page emotionally before they set
off to do something like go on a hunt or
engage in a plan more
but um we don't even know whether
they're using specific landscape
features to
um hunt uh Craig Packer always says that
his Lions would form
um you know they would use where Creeks
came together and formed a cul-de-sac
lions are smart enough to use that as a
as a fence basically into which they
taste prey so
um do hyenas do that I wouldn't be
surprised but the fission fusion nature
of their society allows them to go apart
to do stuff like hunting because
um if you're a low ranking hyena you
really want to go off by yourself to eat
because if if there's a high ranking
hyena they're with you you won't get
anything at all and then there are clan
wars and these interactions with lions
and we find that group size varies a lot
depending on what the nature of the
activity is so here conflict with lions
here's clan wars and so those have on
average you know a lot of hyenas present
15 or 16 and all the way down to hunting
where the average hunting group size is
something like 1.6 so
um they really don't
spend time there so um
let's see uh yeah so in both clan wars
and lion interactions we have a lot of
communication going on I'm going to show
you a couple of videos and what you'll
see is that
um
well especially in the lion one uh where
the hyenas start up a couple hyenas
stumble across these three Lions who
have actually killed a zebra and they're
eating it and those hyenas the first
ones to arrive call in loads of other
hyenas and very soon you have tons of
hyenas there and they're making just a
phenomenal amount of noise and as soon
as they get rid of those Lions silence
it's really pretty cool anyway
um almost all these events occur where
there's something's been killed like
somebody runs down a wilded beast just
over the Border in somebody else's
territory or whatever
um so individuals
um sometimes get to eat later but others
others don't get to because they're too
low ranking so why do they cooperate all
these Mysteries um exist here and okay I
want to apologize for the cinematography
but you sort of gotta get the sense of
excitement from the person who's in the
back seat trying to film this clan war
situation we've got two teams a big team
the pond Clan over here and the kind of
seeing plan over here
oh
that's a lot of values
[Music]
sometimes opportunities
okay now let me just show you um this
this scene with interacting with lions
and remember a single slap from even a
female lion can [__] a hyena so
you're really a real real quite
dangerous for them but um here let me
see if I can make this go
really
just kill it now
okay
[Music]
hyenas continue to come in from
everywhere
that's some more picture trying to just
take them out on the ground
everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
nasty Lions all right
um yeah so so let me tell you a little
bit about this Kick-Ass project so we
had been um for many years putting radio
collars on hyenas we originally put just
regular VHF ones on then started buying
vectronics collars with uh VHF and GPS
capabilities and then here's reinberg
peskin again with the kind of collars
that we had made to deploy on every
single hyena in a social group and so
here's the battery pack for the um uh
the GPS and the VHF and then there are
um as a sound board and microphone and
one of those things and there's another
one up there that also has accelerometer
magnetometer in it so and here's an
automatic drop off that you can release
remotely from inside the vehicle so
these are very fancy collars they've got
inside uh they have as as I mentioned
they give you a GPS fix every second as
for the whole life of the collar they
record everything the hyena says or
hears for the whole life of the color
and it tells you based on the
accelerometer data how it moved in
response to what it heard so here's what
the color looks like on a
um a finished hyena here's France
putting putting a color on and there's
the finished product and here let me
show you the results of our pilot study
in the fall of 2016 we put um these
fancy colors on six because I didn't
believe that they would work I think
seriously you got a collar with a
microphone that hyenas can go stick
their heads in a bloody giraffe and come
out covered with Gunk or go lie in a mud
puddle all day and they're still working
they said yeah we think we do because we
figured this out for working on marine
mammals and so anyway we have two high
rankers two middle rankers and two low
rankers here keep an eye on magenta
she's this purple dot she's a real loner
but um so here's just the whole month of
January 2017 and they're covering an
area here that's about 70 square
kilometers here's magenta being a loner
by herself but the communal Den was
right here at this time and then it
moved over here so they're coming
together
um to form uh you know these social
units and they all interact and
familiarize themselves with each other's
Cubs and whatnot and then they go apart
to do things like hunt or
feed
so then since that was successful we
actually then decided to move forward
with
um immobilizing all 25 uh members large
enough to wear a collar in uh this other
clan in the Mara and so now we've got
all 25 hyenas
um collared and they all turned all the
collars turned on on January 1st we took
them all they started to die about
Midway through
um February and then we took them all
off by the first of March and
um so we've found that the magnetometer
accelerometer data fall into these three
nice categories of very slow movement
which is typically they're lying around
sleeping and medium activity and then
high levels of activity and all the
individual profiles also have all three
of those Peaks
um and so from the accelerometer data
you can actually see that they're pretty
active between about oh nine o'clock
yeah what's that yeah eight o'clock at
night and um
sorry this is eight o'clock at night yes
and this is six o'clock in the morning
so this is their main sleep period here
except this is obviously a day when
something exciting was happening up
there because you have these blips of
red activity there even in broad
daylight
then what we were able to do was to play
run playback experiments and what we
could do is we had three categories of
loop vocalizations that we had recorded
and then we could all doctor so that
they were all you know exactly the same
um length and the same um
yes had the same parameters but then we
had um one one set of hyenas was from a
clan that lives over here and that's the
voice that you're going to be here this
is the speaker it's going to turn yellow
when the sound turns on and then here's
two hyenas they're lying next to each
other
um and their their reactions are just
wildly individualistic so you can
actually see this one is actually going
to engage in like a border patrol all by
yourself she's going to go way over here
and come back and these other
individuals are sort of
um just scattered around in the habitat
but
yeah now you can see that
that pink girl is moving still no sound
we've got another one here and another
one over there
so we've got alien hyenas from the clan
next door hyenas from this plant and and
hyenas from uh
uh basically a third group that they
that they should be familiar with and
not have a problem with
okay so the sound came on and now this
one is just going to go on this gigantic
circuit this one's going to go back to
sleep under her bush
this this Creek over here is literally
yeah the boundary of the territory
quite a reaction
so now what we're able to do since we've
taken all the collars off and we've done
this on all three of the species now and
we can start to bring the data together
so um sound data with the magnetometer
and the locational data and um we have
uh whoops that in an ideal world would
look like this and um this is a female
she's heavier brawnier than the male is
over here and her voice is deeper
typically and we find that
um the frequencies of the their voices
vary with with their chest girth
probably with other parameters as well
but
um anyway we have
um this pretty dramatic variation based
on Section Eight so you can actually
tell who swooping is it a male or female
is it a kid or not
um based on that and here's what the the
guy who's actually doing the artificial
intelligence uh work for us is a German
physicist and I love this because this
is his slide how does the data look so
here he goes here's some vocalizations
without
um much deterioration and noise so
you've got to call there and a call
there and here you've got some some
noise and here is you got what what we
see all the time which is the hyenas are
constantly walking through grass the
meerkats are constantly digging for
scorpions and other invertebrates and
they um
you know if there's a ton of stuff here
and as Shane had asked the other day was
there a particular part of this whole
process that's um extremely challenging
yes it's finding the time to listen to
all of this stuff so
um it just takes forever and so we've
got you know all these meerkats and all
these kawadis and all these hyenas now
with tons and tons of data and
uh somebody's gonna have to do a lot of
listening okay that's really all I
wanted to say so I will just say thank
you
thank you
yes so um
you said before that
each individual has its own whoop
um but is this exclusively vocalized by
the individual or do the other members
of the client also vocalize them no we
we have no reason to believe that hyenas
can do what what Mickey was showing you
the elephants can do no I think it's a
broad the general broadcast and all the
members of the clan know
um you know and they typically will also
know you know the voices of their other
neighbors and so if you play
um a neighbor's voice from inside the
territory they get all upset and if you
play the neighbor's voice from where the
terror where the neighbor lives nobody
cares they recognize but they don't
vocalize yeah yeah they will recognize
that yeah that's joshimo next door thank
you
foreign
again that figure is so incredible I
don't I don't for the computer
scientists in the room that's like
gpt3 if you had to write all of the text
that went into generating it in the
first place so that's amazing and I'm I
I'm gonna put it on my wall
um but the the playback experiment the
orange animal that did the patrol versus
the blue one who who did not what was
the stat like the rank status between
the two of them
um famous middle ranking and I can't
remember what the blue one was um but
she's younger and so I part of her
response was that she's just a young
adult female who's everything is sort of
new and exciting okay cool fascinating I
remember France telling me about this
about we're gonna put continuous audio
on whatever I think 24 animals and I was
like okay well annotation is going to be
a beast exactly and then that was 2017.
so machine learning exploded anyhow it's
amazing yeah no it's really it's been
very exciting for us but you know we
need all those different kind of calls
there's there's hard we're hoping that
somebody can develop the software to
pull those things out so we don't really
have to physically listen to all the
thousands of hours of swishing through
grass
well I think that's like an important
thing that came out of today is like all
the biologists are facing similar
challenges in terms of what seem like
obvious and machine learning problems
right and I think that's that's what's
amazing about seti but I just to the
room there's that challenge those few
challenges are everywhere in in Animal
by acoustics
um
first a question and then something
about that
um
I'm biased towards audio because that's
what I do
but
you know it occurred to me when you said
that you know they don't vocalize to
each other to coordinate while hunting
to what extent are you aware of other
communication channels like sent or I
don't know what else that they might be
using yeah well we we know that there
was ours and we know that they recognize
each other based on Vision because you
can have a whole bunch of hyenas sitting
at the den and somebody's approaching
from hundreds and hundreds of meters
away down downwind so can't be a scent
that they're responding to and there's
no sound so the you know the appropriate
hyenas at the Den the Cubs of that
female get very excited seeing that
she's coming from a long way up so they
clearly you know recognize each other
visually we also have done um we've
looked at their microbial communities
and the microbial communities in their
scent glands vary dramatically amongst
the Clans so each plant has its unique
scent evidently and then the highness
we've also done experiments where we
know that uh male hyenas for example can
discriminate between a pregnant
um the scent glands secretion of a
pregnant female versus the same female
when she's lactating I mean there's some
pretty subtle cues being being played
there
okay and and listen now the follow-up on
this
um
so it seems like
you know it's a little bit of a chicken
and an egg problem yes you would like to
have uh there's this repeated thought of
wouldn't it be nice if something was
marking up all of our data for us and
segmenting it and of course our first
thought is wouldn't it be nice if you
gave us nice marked up segmented data
um to learn from if if we use something
like
I mean there's obviously machine
learning techniques that can be used to
to sort of automatically cluster things
and and
at some point I I don't know how much
any of you have used Audi that kind of
stuff uh unsupervised learning
techniques to automatically say cluster
or long audio recordings would any of
you have any comments on how well that
has worked for you
but
clustering algorithms that we've worked
with with these high-end vocalizations
don't don't work terribly well actually
experience it
is less frequency modulated calls but
all the all of those species that have
this complex frequency modulation and
the parameters you can extract
have haven't necessarily always
clustered into what were perceived as
different call types so
um so I think it's a it's a
it's a two-sided coin of investing a lot
of time in New extracting new types of
features versus the time it takes to do
that extraction almost so I but I
totally get having worked with setting
now the issue of having a nice data set
on which to build the annotator and the
Chicken and the Egg problem it's for
sure there yeah
that's just fascinating uh what question
maybe I've missed but what's the upward
is there upward mobility in the society
yeah there is some actually and um uh
yeah what we found is that the females
who have Coalition partners with whom
they
um regularly interact and form
coalitions against other hyenas they
actually are are likely to raise
themselves up even if it's just a ranked
position or two that can have a huge
effect on your Fitness so yeah there are
some upward Mobility mostly most of the
interactions you see are just like
coaches and Oliver Twist where they're
you know basically trying to maintain
the status quo
don't want anybody over outranking you
that doesn't right now
all right thank you any any other
questions
that was really wonderful talk and I
really love to hear that the The Marine
Mammal
um Crossover with uh with this work and
uh you're really exciting so
um well thank you
foreign
until
[Music]